اعلنت واشنطن وتوكيو اتفاقهما على تعزيز
التعاون الامني بينهما لمواجهه ما سمىتاه
التهديدات الصينيه وقد اكدت الولايات
المتحده التزامها بدفاع عن اليابان حتى
اذا اقتضى ذلك استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
بينما اعلن الجانبان ان الصين تحد
استراتيجيون لهما من جانبها اكدت بيجيننا
التعاون العسكريه بين واشنطن وتوكيو يجب
ان لا يضر بمصالح طرف ثالث
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الرسائل التي
يحملها اتفاق طوكيو واشنطن على تعزيز
التعاون الامني بينهما وما مغزا اشاره
وزير الدفاع الامريكي بالامكانيه استخدام
القوه النوويه للدفاع عن اليابان وعلى اي
نحو يمكن ان تقرا بجين تاكيد الجانبين
الامريكي والياباني انزعاجه ما مما
يسميانه التهديدات الصينيه وما هو الطرف
الثالث الذي تحذر من توجيه الاتصال
ما هي المسارات التي يمكن ان يتخذها
التوتر المتصاعد بالمنطقه في ظل سباق
التسلح واتفاقيه الدفاع وتبادل رسائل
التهديد بين مختلف الاطراف الفاعل فيها
[موسيقى]
قبيله قمه امريكيه يابانيه في واشنطن يوم
الجمعه وبعيده توقيع اتفاقيه دفاعيه
مشتركه
يوم الاربعاء
عن بعضهما اذا دعت الضروره وتتيح لكل
منهما نشر قوته في البلد الاخر اعلن
الجانبان الامريكي والياباني التوافق على
تعزيز دفاع بينهما عبر ترتيبات جديده تتيح
للمؤسسات الدفاعيه في البلدين التعاون
الوثيق في مجال التقنيات المتطوره الاتفاق
الذي اعلنه في واشنطن وزراء الخارجيه
والدفاع في بلدين جميله ايضا تعميقه
التعاون مع الشركاء مثل استراليا واوروبا
واكد ان الصين تعتبر التحدي الاكبر لهما
ولحلفائهما وقد جددت واشنطن في سياق
الاتفاق الذي ياتي بعد اسابيع فقط من
اعلاني طوكي وعزمها مضاعفه ميزانيتها
العسكريه بحلول عام 2027 وجدت التزامها
بدفاع عن اليابان
لما اوتيت من قوه بما في ذلك القوه
النوويه
[موسيقى]
نقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا من واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث بالمركز العربي
في واشنطن ومن باريس الدكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه الامريكيه
في باريس مرحبا بكمام دكتور زياد
استراتيجيه الامن القومي اليابانيه الاولى
في 2013
جاء فيها ان العلاقه المستقره بين اليابان
والصين عامل اساسي للسلام والاستقرار في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ اليوم ما الذي
تغير دكتور
ما يتغير هو المعطيات الدوليه واعاده رسم
خريطه العلاقات الدوليه مع عوده روسيا على
الاقل من الناحيه العسكريه للعديد من
الصراعات ومع صعود الاقتصادي الصيني الذي
سيستمر ويتواصل بحلول العام 2030 كما ان
الصين التي تنمو اقتصاديا
وبتلها تبادل اقتصادي مع الكثير من الدول
يتقدم حتى على التبادل الامريكي مع هذه
الدول لديها طموح سياسي ان تلعب دورا اكبر
وهو ما يقلق عددا من جيرانها كما انه يقلق
بالطبع على الولايات المتحده التي تفضل ان
تبقى لها في العلاقات الدوليه وفي
العلاقات السياسيه عامه من هنا محاوله
ازهار ان خلفاء امريكا في المحيط الاطلسي
وتحديدا جيران الصين وفي مقدمه من اليابان
ليسوا ماتركين واحدين
هناك همم يعني دعم امريكي مستمر لهذه
الدول واليابان كما كوريا الجنوبيه
بتتاخشيان من تسارع التطورات خاصه بعد
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وبعد التجارب
النوويه الكوريه الشماليه وفي ظل التوسع
الصيني ربما هناك تبدل جاهلي يجري الان لا
يعني ان حوبا ستقع لكن يعني ان توتر
والتنافس متى يشمل معظم همم مساحات هذه
الكره الارضيه بما فيها المناطق التي
حسبنا لفتره بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
انها لم تشهد تطورات كبيره من هذا النور
سوف
تتوتر هذا لاحقا في المنطقه همم دكتور
خليل همم هل موقف اليابان الان
مرتبط بمخاوف غربيه خاصه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من الصين اكثر منه
مخاوف يابانيه
واكثر بمخاوف يابانيه من توسع الصيني
راينا وشاهدنا وسمعنا قبل اقل من اسبوعين
هناك مسيرات صينيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي
وايضا هناك اختراق لمنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه لجمال في تلك المنطقه كما خوف
يابانيه جزء منها متعلقه
الدولي من خلال حرب الروسيه على القران
التي عدد بشكل او باخر التعريف العلاقات
الدوليه واعاده تعريف الاوزان وهناك
التحول الاستراتي يحدث الان في منطقه
المحيط الهادي هو منطقه همم شرق اسيا
وبالتالي هناك استعداد ياباني بشكل او
باخر التعاقد متغيرات الجديده جزء منه
متعلق بالتحول كبير جدا في حقيقه الامن
القومي الياباني كما تفضل استاذ جلال وقلت
في بدايه المقدمه هذه الحلقه هناك تحول
كبير جدا حدث قبل حوالي شهر من الان عندما
تم اصدار عقيده الامن القومي الياباني
الجديده وبها تحولات مهمه جدا اولها فيما
يتعلق بيرفع الانفاق العسكري في تحول كبير
جدا ده حوالين 2% من الميزانيه الناس اللي
حوالي 320$ سنويا كما بالحصول على منظومه
دفاع صاروخيه جديده ليست فقط من اجل
الدفاع لكن ايضا من اجل الهجوم وسد هجمات
قد تكون صينيه كوريه شماليه هناك ايضا نوع
من التحالف فيما يتعلق بالسلاح النووي
وتطول سلاح الجو وبالتالي هناك ما خوف
يابانيه واضحه جدا بلا شك طبعا مركز
استغلال غرب لهذه المساله وايضا الامر
متعلق بمحاوله تعزيز امريكا لقواتها في
تلك المنطقه العالم جميع ان هناك تواجد
امريكا عسكري مده على الاقل 78 سنه وانتم
بتحب العالميه الثانيه هناك تنافس لم يكن
صراع الصيني امريكي على الارض وعلى السماء
وعلى الفضاء وبالتالي هناك حاجه لتعزيز
الوجود الامريكي هناك من خلال التحالف
وتوقيع اتفاقيه كما جاء قبل قليل الدفاع
مشترك وهذا يعتبر تحول نوع كبير لماذا
اولا ماذا يعني ان هناك امكانيه لاستخدام
القوه العسكريه الامريكيه بشكل مباشر في
الدفاع عن اليابان همم وذلك وفقا
الاتفاقيه الجديده هناك نوع من اي تهديد
اللي طالعه في مثل هذه الطرف الاخر
والثاني متعلق بقى ان التحدي الرئيس اللي
كانت بين الصين على الامر جاء على اللسان
اكثر المسؤوله امريكا وكان في استراتيجيه
الامن القوائم من امريكا تستضيف قبل حوالي
اربعه اشهر من الان هناك تحديدا حديث حول
اعتبار الصين تحديان استراتيجيا الامر
بالنسبه اليابان وبالتالي هناك استخدام
هذه المساله فيما يتعلق بالصراع في تلك
المنطقه المترهله دكتور زياد انت همم
استبعت نشوب حرب او حروب في هذه المنطقه
كيف
تفهم همم حديث وزير الدفاع الامريكي بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ستدافع عن
اليابان بكل ما اتيت بقوه بما فيها القوه
النوويه واحنا نعلم بان الصين تطور قوتها
النوويه ورؤوسها النوويه ايضا في تزايد
طبعا الموضوع مهم جدا كما تريح لان الصين
دوله نوويه كما تفضلت كوريا الشماليه على
الارجوح دوله نوويه
واليابان لا تملك سلاح النوويه تملك
برامجا نوويه سلميه
وبالتالي القول الامريكي هو نوع من
الرساله لببجي
انا عدم وجود قرشانه نوويه يابانيه لا
يعني ان اليابان ستكون معقوله او سيستغرب
بها نوويه هناك بهذا المعنى او مظله
عسكريه امريكيه تقدم لليابانيين وهناك
رساله واضحه همم لجين المفارقه همم وتفضل
الدكتور عنان ذكرها انها الموازنه
العسكريه اليابانيه تماما كما الموازنه
العسكريه الالمانيه في اوروبا وهما همم
طبعا همم دوله همم كانت همم ضمن موازنه
محدوده بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه بدا
تتطور كثيره
توقيع اتفاقات عسكريه اضافيه
مع انجلترا ثم مع الولايات المتحده اضافه
الى كل التعاون العسكري في المنطقه الذي
يضم استراليا ايضا يظهر ان ال- همم
الترسانات العسكريه والموازنات العسكريه
ستتوسع
والكلام عن السلاح النووي هو من اجل تغطيه
هذه الترسانات التقليديه في مواجهه الصين
وكوريا الشماليه همم كما ذكرنا على ثاني
تملكان الاسلحه النوويه ولكن ايضا تظهر ان
ال- العالم في اعاده رسم توازناته يتبدل
همم مره جديده من دون ان يعني ذلك الذهاب
نحو مواجهه عسكريه وانما اظهار ان اليابان
بوسعها الدفاع عن نفسها امام الصين هناك
خلاف في الحقيقه حول جزر بين الصين
واليابان وهناك خلافات بالطبع همم بين
الصين تايوان كبيره حول كل المستقبل
تايوان
كل هذا براي مترابط يعني ان هناك كباشا
وتنافسا من دون ان يكون مقدمه لحروب قد
مقبله طيب طبعا الصين كان لها موقف بجين
اكتفت تعقيبا على اعلان طوكيو واشنطن
تعزيز الدفاع بينهما بالقول ان هذه الخطوه
يجب الا تضر بمصالح طرف ثالث او بالسلام
والاستقرار الاقليميين ياتي هذا رغم ان
الطرفيه الاتفاق اعرب صراحه عن قلقهما
بسبب الصين
تحديا الاستراتيجيا غير مسبوق وسياستها
الخارجيه تهدف الى اعاده صياغه النظام
العالمي لخدمه مصالحها وهو امر يؤرق
التحالف اليابانيه الامريكيه والمجموعه
الدوليه وستظل اليابان والولايات
المتحدهتين في الاعتراض على محاولات الصين
تغيير الوضع القائم في بحر شرقي الصين كما
جدد الاعتراضنا على مطالب بيجين غير
القانونيه واستفزازاتها في بحر جنوبي
الصين وجدنا التزامنا بعدم تغيير الوضع في
تايوان
دكتور خليل طبعا اليابان كانت طرفا في
الحوار الامني الرباعي عام 2021 والذي عرف
ب ااا الناتو الاسيوي بالهدف احتواء
النفوذ الصيني في المنطقه ما الحسابات
الامريكيه المتعلقه باليابان هذه الجزيره
التي تخلصت على ما يبدو من وزر الارحل
العالميه الثانيه
انا اعتقد الحسابات المتعلقه بالاساس
بالصين هناك سعي امريكي واضح جدا على مدار
اخر ست سنوات على الاقل باحتواء الصين
وهناك اكثر من النظريه في هذا الاطار التي
تقول بان الصعود الصيني لن يكون صعودا
سليميا خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاقتصاد
بالتكنولوجيا بالتحول الاستراتيجي
والعسكري هناك خاصه في ظل التحرر داخلها
في الصين وسيطره تشنج بنت على السلطه هناك
بشكل كبير جدا وبالتالي هناك ساعه امريكي
واضح جدا بدا على الاقل لمده حوالي عقد
ونصف مع وصول اداره التبول السلطه فيما
يتعب يتعلق فيما يسمى بيفيد تو ايجيا او
التحول باتجاه اسيا والجهات الهادي امريكي
في ما يتعلق هذه المساله يترجم في عده
امور الامر متعلق بتقويه الدفاعات
والتخلفات الاقليميه وراينا مثلا قبل
حوالي عام ونصف من الان همم انشاء تحالف
وقوس بين استراليا وامريكا الذي يعني
بالاساس بانشاء او بوجود تطوير منظومه
مئويه قد تمثل نوع من الرد على الصين هناك
ايضا تحالف وقود والذي يضم او يعني انشئ
قبل حوالي اكثر من 15 عام يضم
بالاضافه الى اليابان وامريكا استراليا
والهند ايضا ايضا في اطار محاوله احتواء
صعود الصين وبالتالي هناك السعي امريكي
همم الاحتواء الصين للنتيجه للشعور ان
الصيلا ان يكون سعوديه سلميه بان يكون قد
يكون صعودا عسكريا راينا ايضا قبل حوالي
اربعه شهور زياره قامت بها رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي السابقه لنانسي بروسيا
الى تايوان هذا يعتبر نوع من التحول في
الموقف الامريكي من الصراع على تايوان
فيما يتعلق بالسياده الصينيه عليها
وبالتالي هناك ايضا ساعي امريكي للتاكيد
على وجود دعم قوي جدا لحلفائها سواء كان
في ما يتعلق باليابان قريه الجنوبيه
تايوان او الهند الهند وبالتالي الجزء ليس
متعلق باليابان بحد ذاتها متعلق بالاساس
بيسعى امريكا لوجود نوع من المظله الامنيه
كما قال الدكتور زياد نوع من التحالف
الدفاعي وهذا يعتبر تحول اليوم يعني
بنتكلم على الكره قبل قليل لاول مره يتم
توقيع اتفاقيه الدفاع مشترك بما يعني اي
تهديد طرف يمثل هذه الطرف يعتبر نوع من
التحول في تلك المنطقه همم تركزين على
الصين طيب دكتور همم زياد همم
هذه التحالفات لليابان هل تضعف النفوذ
الصيني في هذه المنطقه المشاهد الان ربما
يعني يتخيل الخريطه الخريطه الصينيه
والخريطه اليابانيه كيف يمكن هذا التحالف
ان يضعف او يزعج النفوذ الصيني في المنطقه
يمتد التحالف من اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
حتى استراليا بمعنى انه يشكل نوع من القوس
في جنب الصين والهدف منه هو رساله اا
للصينيين ان الصعود الاقتصادي الذي لا محر
منه في كل الاحوال بسبب النمو الصناعي
وبسبب سياسه الدوله الصينيه ينبغي ان لا
يترافق مع مقام عسكريه او مع توسع تراب
جغرافي صيني وبالتالي بين الاتفاقات مع
استراليا مع كوريا مع اليابان وهمم وضع
بريطانيا من هذه التحالفات هناك نوع من
الحصار او همم كلمه كبيره ربما نوع من همم
الجدار الذي يمكن ان يظهر وكانه مواجهه
للصين يمنع توسعها او يهدد هذا التوسع ان
كان هناك رغبه في بيجين
عليه اا بيبي بجعله امرا واقعا سياسيا
وعسكريا
ويمكن ايضا ان نضيف عنصر اساسيا بكل ما
يجري في هذه المنطقه وهو الحجم
الديموغرافي لهذه المنطقه وترجمته
اقتصاديه
وترجمته على صعيد التبادل السلعي على صعيد
همم
التاثير الامني على معظم المعموره همم
تقريبا نصف سكان الكره الارضيه هم بين
الصين والهند وباكستان
ومنطقه اندونيسيا وصوله الى اليابان والى
كوريا هناك همم ثقل ديموغرافي كبير
وبالتالي التحولات الغربيه على اعتبار ان
هذه المنطقه قد تكون اولويه على اكثر من
صعيددات منذ سنوات وتستمر جاءت الحرب
الروسيه لتكون همم فيما يتعلق بالاوروبيين
ربما همم منطقه همم توتر كبير همم
بطه من التحول نحو اسيا لكن بالنسبه
لامريكا لم
تقطيرا سياسه تحول نحو اسيا تستمر بس
بب ترافي الى حد ما بسبب تاريخ علاقات
وبسبب حضور عسكري امريكي كبير منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه في المنطقه في اليابان
تحديدا لكن ايضا في جزر اخرى عبر الاساطير
البحريه الدكتور خليل الكل يراقب الان
الصبر الصيني همم ازاء ما تعتبره بجين
استفزازات امريكيه متتاليه سواء كان فيما
يتعلق بجزيره تايوان او حتى في هذه
التحالفات في المنطقه ما الانعكاسات
المحتمله على الساحات الدوليه في الملفات
المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين
اولا نتحدث الاول عن كيفيه كيف تكون الصين
التعاطي مع زيت تحولات لاسترجاعتك المنطقه
اعتقد الامر يتم من خلال عده محاور محور
المتعلم بمحافظه الصين يعني علاقات جديده
مع حلفاء جدد فيما يتعلق مثل بتقويه
الجبهه الصينيه الروسيه
على سبيل المثال قبل حوالي اربعه اسابيع
او اقل من ذلك القمه العربيه الصينيه لاول
مره التي تقوم من خلال وجود هذا نوع من
التعاون الاقتصادي والاستراتيجي جزانت
ايضا ثالث متعلق بتفعيل مبادره الحزام
والطريق التي سوف تعطل الصين نوع من
النفوس الاقتصادي العالمي يمتد من اسيا
وحتى امريكا اللاتينيه ليه مواجهه هذه
الامور من خلال هذه هذه
الاستراتيجيات الامر الاخر كان سؤال حضرتك
جلال متعلق بيتحول في في الساحه الدوله
اعتقد انه البؤره المقبله لاي النزاع او
حرب ستكون في جنوب اسيا جنوب شرق اسيا
لماذا كما قلنا قبل قليل هناك نوع
الاحتواء الامريكي وتوابل عسكري الامريكي
وتفضل دكتور زياد وقال هناك تواجد عسكري
امريكي منذ على الاقل همم سبعه عقود
بنتكلم على الاقل 50,000 في جندي امريكا
موجودين في خمس جزر اليابانيه اهمها في
كناوه على الاقل هناك تواجد عسكري امريكي
في كوريا الجنوبيه في
تحالف عسكري مع تايوان وبالتالي هناك نوع
من الاستعداد العسكري الامريكي
العيساويين لاي التحرك صيني في تلك
المنطقه وبالتالي اي توتر قد يحدث مثلا من
خلال مناورات عسكريه من خلال طائرات مسيره
كما قال كمال كماجيه قبل قليل فما يتعلق
باسماء على الجزر الصينيه اليابانيه وجوز
اليابانيه التي تتدعى اسنانها تحت سادات
هي قد يؤدي الى انفجار الاوضاع الدخول في
حرب مثلا اذا قامت الصناعه سبيل المثال
بمحاوله ضم تايوان بالقوه قد ذلك الانطلاع
حرب وبالتالي اعتقد البؤره القادمه من
خلال عقود القادمه البؤره الملتهبه
القادمه متى تكون تلك المنطقه من العالم
في جنوب اسيا همم هذا يطرح سؤال عن دكتور
زياد
معارضوه سياسه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاسيه ما في المنطقه في المحيط الهادئ
وشرق اسيا يقولون انظر ما حصل في اوروبا
باوكرانيا اوكرانيا تركت وحيده على الارض
نعم هناك دعم بالسلاح وما شابه ولكن انظر
ما حصل بها همم هذا التحول في السياسه
اليابانيه هل يضع طوكيو في مواجهه الصين
وربما لا تستطيع على تحمله في حال وقع
النزاع انت تستبعده ولكن الدكتور خليل
يقول بانه ممكن
يعني انا اتفق مع دكتور خليل ان هذه
المنطقه قد تكون همم بؤره التوترات وتنافس
كبير اقتصادي وسياسي مع كلوها ان استبعاد
الحرب همم يرتبط بالبعض النووي المباشر
لها بسبب يعني السلاح النووي الصيني بسبب
الان الاتفاقات الامريكيه التي تهدف الى
اظهار ان هناك توازن نوويا مقابله وعاده
فكره التوازن النووي هي لتفادي اصطدام كما
ان اصطدام هناك كبير جدا
حتى الان الصين تحاول ان تكرس صعودها
الاقتصادي من خلال علاقات تنتجها في
افريقيا في امريكا الجنوبيه في اسيا ذاتها
وتراهن على الحاجه لمنتجاتها في الاسواق
الغربيه همم اظهرت رغبه في تفادي الصراعات
وفوضت حوله كونج ثم فرضت سيادتها ولو ايضا
قمعها لسكان هونج كونج تحاول تفادي صراع
في تايوان ولو انها تلوح به وابدت حتى
انزعاجا ما من التصعيد الروسي في اوكرانيا
لانها لا تريد ان يكون لحلفها مع روسيا مع
يعقل هذا الصعود الدولي ويعرضها لعقوبه في
ما يخص اليابان
ربما ايضا الخوف مما حصل في اوكرانيا اذ
لم تكن عضوا في حلف شمال الاطلسي ولم تشمل
اوكرانيا
معاهدات واتفاقات ردع مشترك ودفاع عنها
استخرج بها والدعم العسكري لها بدا متاخرا
ربما هناك رغبه في السباق كل ذلك من خلال
انضمام الى منظومات دفاع مع بريطانيا ومع
امريكا ومن خلال التلويح بالرد عن النووي
في حال ارادت الصين او كوريا الشماليه
التهويل به او التهديد باستخدامه لذلك
اختراع يكونوا محتدي مع الاقتصاديه عن
واديتلوماسيه واضح لكن مشيرته العسكريه
حصلت
انطلاقا هذا القلق باقتضاب شديد دكتور
خليل بالحديث عن مقالات تصعيد لا بد من
الحديث عن الجغرافيا مثلا المجال الحيوي
الياباني يعتمد بصوره كبيره على الوصول
الى الممرات المشتركه مع الصين واحنا نعلم
بان اليابان بلد مصدر لكثير من السلع
انطلاقا من هنا ما نقلت التصعيد بين
البلدين باقتضاب لو سمحت
بشكل عام همم هناك ساعه من خلال الاطراف
من ثلاث طرفين بعدم وجود نوع من النزاع
المباشر بينهم وهم هناك كما قلت استاذ
جلال هناك حاجه لوجود نوع من التهديه خاصه
فيما يتعلق البعض الاقتصاد والتكنولوجي
هناك حاجه يابانيه وحاجه صينيه لوجود او
الوصول المنتجاتهم للتكنولوجيا
والاقتصاديه الى الدول العالم
اضطرت الامور اللي موجوده النزاع ونعمل
الصراع خاصه في ظل وجود كما قلت قبل قليل
مقام الصينيه بشكل اخر في بعض الجزر
اليابانيه قد نشد نوع من الانطلاع نوع من
الحرب وقد تتحول للاسف الشديد الحرب
العالميه الثالثه لا تحدث في المستقبل
القريب شكرا الدكتور خليل العناني في
واشنطن والدكتور زياد ماجد في باريس
الى هنا تنتهي الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى
اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]